hey what's up my name is samuel lees and
in this video i'm going to be giving you
my condensed
12 years in business on this little
video
about how to put together a business
plan how to have a plan
to succeed in property or any business
as it happens i've used the street
succeed in property but this will work
for just about any business
so take good notes listen up closely but
the very first thing you need to do to
succeed in property or any business is
this
you need to smash the like button okay
so smash the like button subscribe to
the channel
and then let me talk to you a bit about
business planning so very first thing
um business planning is basically very
similar
to goal setting now i'm not talking
about how to write a business plan
necessarily that you're going to present
to the bank okay to try and get funding
i'm talking about how to have a business
plan that's going to help you
win in property most people
they don't even have proper goals they
don't have a plan they don't know the
difference between
goals between targets between strategies
and it's just wrong i mean i'll say i'll
say to someone what what's the goal
and it's like oh um um to get three
properties
that's not a goal that's a target what's
the goal oh um
um to be making 10 grand a month that's
not a goal that's a target
oh um no wonder people are failing
imagine for a minute if there was a
group of football players
that didn't know that the incentive of
the game was to kick the ball into the
net
you know what was the plan oh you know
they'd be kicking the football around
doing headers passing it back and forth
to each other and that's how most people
do business and that's why most people
fail
oh i'll do a few viewings make a couple
calls
go to a few networking events have a bit
of a chin wag let's hope to see what
happens
no you have a really clear plan so
here's what we're going to do right now
okay
i want you to write down on a piece of
paper goals
so you get your goals next targets
and then next strategies those are the
three aspects to a business plan it's
goals
it's targets it's strategies so
goals this is personal goals because
your business plan
be under no illusion the purpose of a
business is to
facilitate your personal goals maybe
your personal goals
are to help a bunch of people to dig
some wells in rural africa and bring
clean water to some villages great
that was part of my personal goal maybe
your personal goal is to
be able to go on holiday three times a
year to travel the world to live in a
nice
big house to drive a nice range rover
whatever these are goals these are
personal goals
okay so you want to write down what are
your goals what's the real reason for
doing this who you want to help where do
you want to go
okay that's the very first thing there's
a personal goals
next is targets financial targets a
target
is how much money you need to achieve in
order to facilitate that goal
so let's say your goal is to live in a
nice big house to drive a range rover to
do the
whatever you might want to do great
they're your goals that's the reason why
cool next how much money do you need to
facilitate that goal
you want to live in a nice big house you
have to pay the rent the mortgage
so write down how much you need and then
you write and then suddenly
it might be a case of right to live that
life i
need to be a millionaire i need to be
making 20 000 pounds a month in passive
income
because it's not just about money it's
also about lifestyle and i want to be
taking all these holidays
i wanna i need to be making this much
money i need to have this much turnover
i need to have okay cool
targets and then next is strategies what
strategy
are you gonna use to create that wealth
to get that passive income to hit that
target
is it going to be rent to rent is it
going to be lease option agreements
is it going to be deal packaging and
people say to me all the time samuel
what's the best strategy
what strategy should i do and i'm like
until you get clear on your goals
i can't answer that question are you
looking to get cash flow
are you wanting fast pound or you want
in slow
pound which is they're both good they're
just different are you wanting to
build wealth are you wanting to grow a
portfolio to leave a legacy
very different from i need i need to my
goal is to quit my job and i need 3 000
pounds a month in
in income it doesn't have to be passive
it's a very different goal
it's a different target it's a different
strategy so if you want to get really
clear
on your strategy okay i've put together
a webinar and it's it's basically the
purpose of the webinar
is to put together your bespoke
strategy so that you have goals targets
clear strategies the webinar is free
it's free to attend so if you're
interested
click the link below go through to the
webinar i'll see you on the other side
if you enjoyed the video
smash the like button subscribe i look
forward to seeing you on the other side
on the webinar
link in the description i'll see you
[Music]
there